[Music]
there have been numerous world renowned
prison escapes spanning across the
decades we'll let's take a look at the
most ingenious ones the escaped that
took the most planning dedication and
outright bravery joy gap-bok South
Korean prisoner choi gap-bok escaped by
squeezing himself through the food slots
of his cell door you know the small slot
on every prison door yes that's right he
actually contorted his whole body
through a hole only 15 centimeters tall
and 43 centimeters wide choi gap-bok was
50 and in prison for burglary he had
spent most of his life in prison and
regularly practiced yoga which must've
aided his escape
one night before lights-out he asked a
prison guard for a special skin ointment
which they gave to him I'm sure the
guard didn't think he will be using it
to squeeze for a prison door choi
gap-bok was only 5 foot 4 inches which
helped but it's still a bloody
impressive feat no matter your size he
squeezed his entire body through the
hole in only 30 seconds
unfortunately he was caught again only 6
days later and put into another cell
with a smaller food slot Frank Abagnale
Frank Abagnale the infamous car bomb
that Leonardo DiCaprio played in the
film catch me if you can have
successfully impersonated pilots
teachers doctors and lawyers so liking
his way out of prison was nothing short
of a day's work
Frank was imprisoned for 12 years for
fraud but he got a stroke of luck when
in 1971 the US Marshal transporting him
forgot his detention commitment papers
Frank took this opportunity to subtly
drop the hint to one of the guards that
he might actually be an undercover
prison inspector
disguise dozen inmates so the guards
gave him preferential treatment he then
called his friends jeans Sabri who had
been previously visited by the FBI agent
in charge of Frank's case the FBI agent
Joe Shea had left his business card with
gene gene then pretended to be a
magazine reporter reporting on prisons
to also get the business card of a
prison inspector she visited Frank
Abagnale in prison
posing as his fiancee and slipped him
both business cards Frank used the
prison inspectors business card to prove
to his guards that he was in fact an
undercover inspector he told the guards
it was imperative that he speak to the
FBI immediately Frank handed them the
FBI agents business card but of course
Frank's friend Jean sbrick had already
doctored the card so it displayed her
number instead
Jean picked up the phone posing as the
FBI Jean said she needed to meet with
Frank right outside the prison
immediately the guards happily obliged
after all they didn't want to get on the
wrong side of a prison inspector and an
FBI agent
the guards watched as Frank Abagnale
walk right out of the prison to be
collected by gee and they both rode off
into the sunset guilty as hell John
Dillinger
John Dillinger had already escaped from
another prison in 1933 using smuggled in
rifles so in 1934 when he was arrested
again for a bank heist he was placed in
the Lake County Jail which was known as
escape proof the jail was constantly
guarded by an army of policemen a
National Guard yet Dillinger still
managed a daring escape by fashioning a
bar of soap to look like a gun he forced
his way out of jail with his soap gun
and cheekily stole the sheriff's fought
to make his getaway but he was later
caught by the
yeah The Great Escape no prison escape
in history has ever come close to the
complexity of the Great Escape
the escape was from Stalag Luft 3 a
german prison in operation during World
War two it took about one year and the
efforts of 600 prisoners to dig three
tunnels which they nicknamed Tom Dick
and Harry Latinos were 30 feet deep and
tunneled underneath the main fence the
tunnel required complex systems such as
wooden blocks for support a series of
lumped under electrical wire an air pump
to supply air to the prisoners who were
digging and a rail cart system to move
the earth quicker the tunnels should
have surfaced in a nearby forest but
they dug them a little short
enjoying the actual escape they surfaced
in plain view of the guards consequently
only 76 prisoners escaped all but three
of the escapees were eventually caught
by the Nazis cold ins
the infamous world war ii german
prisoner of war camp Colvin's
was a castle situated on a cliff
overlooking the town of holdings
there were many attempted escapes from
Colvin's but the best planned of them
all occurred when two British pilots
bill Goldfinch and Jack best plan to
construct a two-man glider Jack and Bill
constructed the glider bit by bit in the
lower attic above the chapel the plan
was to ride the glider from the roof
across the river mould the pair built a
secret wall in the Attic to conceal the
glider the glider was painstakingly
constructed from stolen pieces of wood
such as bed slats and floorboards the
Germans who ran the camp focused their
searches on the tunnels it never struck
them to search the Attic for secret
glider workshops
the war ended and the camp was relieved
by the Allies before Jack and Bill had a
chance to make their escape
however channel 4 made a replica of the
glider in a documentary about the escape
called
escapes and called ins in the
documentary the glider was flown
successfully showing the escape would
have likely been successful thanks for
watching until next time
[Music]
you